[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a América este es el
magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
el FBI arrestó a un joven de 21 años
sospechoso de la filtración de
documentos más grave en Estados Unidos
en la última década se trata de un
empleado de la guardia nacional aérea a
quien se acusa de haber compartido esta
información confidencial en una
plataforma de mensajería instantánea les
contamos de qué se trata
y se cumplen 10 años del atentado en la
maratón de Boston una tragedia nacional
que mostró precisamente como dos
hermanos se radicalizaron a través de
internet el ataque terrorista con una
bomba de fabricación casera que estalló
en la línea de meta acabó con la vida de
tres personas
y las autoridades sanitarias de México
están al acecho de cirujanos falsos que
ofrecen intervenciones estéticas a bajo
costo a las mujeres que buscan moldear
su cuerpo para adaptarlo al estereotipo
impuesto por la narcocultura el equipo
de France 24 en Sinaloa habló con
algunas Víctimas de estas malas
prácticas
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal el FBI arrestó a Jack
tejeira un joven de 21 años que
trabajaba en la guardia nacional aérea
de Estados Unidos y filtró documentos
clasificados en la que constituye la
mayor divulgación de papeles oficiales
desde Wikileaks en ellos había
información de la estrategia de la Casa
Blanca en Ucrania hacia Corea del Norte
entre otro material sensible la
publicación llegó primero a una
plataforma de mensajería instantánea
llamada discord que es popular entre los
Gamers los aficionados a los videojuegos
discord nació en San Francisco en 2015
principalmente para que los jugadores en
línea hablaran pero se ha convertido en
una alternativa para los desencantados
con las redes sociales tradicionales en
ella se pueden crear espacios virtuales
en las que los usuarios pueden chatear y
compartir documentos Con quienes tienen
intereses similares
tejeira era el líder de un grupo online
de Gamers ultraconservadores religiosos
y amantes de las armas
en France 24 le preguntamos al doctor
Luis noguero el presidente de Advance
division of informatics and Technology
Cómo llegaron documentos tan sensibles a
una plataforma de este tipo y esto fue
lo que nos dijo muy buena pregunta muy
buena pregunta yo creo que es importante
conocer primero que es discord es otra
aplicación similar a WhatsApp similar a
Viper por ejemplo por solo mencionar dos
de las más conocidas en las que la
comunicación se establece a través de un
sistema de boeisover IP o el sistema
sobre el pin no quiere decir que la
comunicación con la internet se facilita
sustantivamente por la forma en la que
la aplicación en sí funciona Qué se
puede hacer en discord número uno se
puede transmitir en vivo lo mismo que
WhatsApp y lo mismo que Skype tiene otra
flexibilidad eso es lo que hace
diferente Pero bueno se puede transmitir
video en vivo se pueden transmitir con
conversaciones en vivo se puede
transmitir
pueden mandar fotografías etcétera Para
qué se usa discord no solo para un tema
de comunicación social sino también se
crean salas para responder su preguntas
en que solo los miembros de la sala que
tienen permiso a acceder a la misma o al
contenido que se comparta en la misma lo
pueden ver pero también puede ser una
transmisión abierta significa que todas
las personas que en ese momento estén
conectadas en ese canal de discord van a
poder ver el contenido que se está
compartiendo
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque se
cumplen diez años del atentado
terrorista en la maratón de Boston el 15
de abril de 2013 dos bombas estallaron
cerca de la línea de meta matando a tres
personas e hiriendo al menos 264 más la
tragedia conmocionó a la Ciudad de
Boston Y puso en alerta a todo el país
mientras las autoridades se movilizaban
para localizar a los responsables de
este acto el informe es de Andrés bonsel
la maratón más antigua de Estados Unidos
Boston acoge desde 1897 uno de los
eventos más importantes del país la
carrera se lleva a cabo en un día de
fiesta y es un símbolo Nacional de
alegría y fraternidad
pero la edición de 2013 fue diferente
[Música]
los explosiones en la línea de meta
convirtieron la celebración en una
tragedia
[Aplausos]
los artefactos detonaron dos horas
después de que el ganador cruzara la
línea de meta los más de 5.700
corredores aún no habían acabado tras
analizar la zona las autoridades
denominaron el hecho como un acto
terrorista y el FBI se hizo cargo de la
investigación
si buscaron intimidarnos aterrorizarnos
ya debería estar bastante Claro que
eligieron la ciudad equivocada para
hacerlo no aquí en Boston No aquí en
Boston Ese es el mensaje que enviamos a
los que llevaron a cabo esto y a
cualquiera que le haga daño a nuestra
gente sí los encontraremos Y sí
enfrentarán la justicia
los reportes iniciales apuntaron a dos
bombas de fabricación casera durante
días las agencias de inteligencia
analizaron miles de vídeos y cámaras de
seguridad identificando a dos
sospechosos tras difundir las imágenes
fueron identificados como taberland
sarnaev y su carta naef hermanos de una
familia de origen checheno residente
ambos en Estados Unidos desde 2003
el 19 de abril los dos sospechosos
asesinaron a un policía y secuestraron a
un joven de origen chino que finalmente
pudo escapar y los delató en el
enfrentamiento con la policía uno de los
sospechosos murió y el otro huyó al día
siguiente fue encontrado escondido en un
pequeño bote
tras la captura del segundo sospechoso
las calles de Boston se llenaron de
júbilo
vamos ahora a Brasil para revisar la
cifra de la semana 100 días cumplió Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva como presidente de
Brasil y en su discurso televisado
prometió un futuro económico mejor para
el país más acciones contra la violencia
machista y racista y más compromiso en
defensa del medio ambiente también
aprovechó para cargar contra su
predecesor Yahir bolsonaro y su legado
que tachó de fascista Lula da Silva ganó
las elecciones con un pequeño margen de
dos puntos porcentuales
y visitemos ahora chile el presidente
Gabriel borich promulgó la ley que
establece que la semana laboral tiene 40
horas con esto el país austral está a la
vanguardia en América Latina miren los
países en rojo es decir México Costa
Rica Nicaragua Panamá Colombia Perú
Bolivia Argentina Paraguay y Uruguay
tienen semanas laborales de Máximo 48
horas en Amarillo Guatemala El Salvador
Honduras República Dominicana Cuba y
Brasil que tienen semanas de 44 horas y
en verde solo Ecuador Venezuela y ahora
chile que tienen 40 horas vamos a
Santiago para la ampliación con la
corresponsal de France 24 Patricia Luna
el presidente chileno Gabriel boric
promulgó este viernes la ley aprobada en
el congreso del martes que reduce la
jornada laboral de los chilenos de 45 a
40 horas semanales una ley que tardó
hasta seis años de tramitarse en el
congreso y en la que mediaron más de 200
reuniones técnicas entre sindicatos y
empleadores y empleados de pequeñas
medianas y grandes empresas en el país y
una ley que tardará cinco años en
implementarse Se pasará de las 45 a 44
horas semanales en el primer año a 42
horas semanales en el tercer año y a 40
horas semanales en el quinto año sin
embargo El Ejecutivo Recuerda que estos
son plazos máximos E invita a las
empresas a adoptar esta legislación lo
antes posible como ya han hecho 500
empresas en el país que adoptaron un
plan piloto y que ya tienen el sello de
40 horas semanales el presidente afirmó
que Cuantos más cuentos se leerán a los
niños y niñas chilenos tras la
implementación de esta Norma que va en
Pos de un mayor bienestar y calidad de
vida para los trabajadores y las
trabajadoras del país y recordó también
que cuando la normativa se ingresó en el
congreso en el 2017 por la actual vocera
del gobierno Camila Vallejo y la
diputada comunista Carol cariola muchas
personas dijeron que no era posible y
que no iba a ocurrir en un lugar como
chile borich agradeció tanto a Vallejo y
a cariola como a suministra del trabajo
Janeth Jara cuya labor fue incansable
para sacar adelante esta normativa que
sitúa a Chile como uno de los países
líderes en esta materia en la región
junto a Ecuador que también tiene una
jornada laboral de 40 horas semanales en
una región del mundo caracterizada por
largas jornadas de trabajo median entre
42 a 45 horas en algunos países y hasta
48 en muchos otros
y a inicios de 2023 magnolia Camacho una
joven mexicana de 29 años murió después
de haberse sometido a más de 30 cirugías
en seis meses en 2021 una joven de 26
años falleció después de una cirugía
estética en el estado mexicano de
Sinaloa los cánones de belleza que se
imponen a las jóvenes hacen que ellas
recurran al bisturí para moldear sus
cuerpos a la semejanza de lo que llaman
la buchona cada vez más mujeres pierden
la vida al acudir a estafadores que las
operan en clínicas clandestinas el
reportaje es del equipo de France 24 en
Culiacán la capital de la cirugía a bajo
costo
estos 17.000 pesos
en el armario de Grecia los zapatos y
vestidos de lujo se cuentan por docenas
la joven de 28 años y su amiga Leslie
invierte en todo su dinero y su tiempo
en su apariencia
las bubis como como 80 en Culiacán
muchas mujeres como Grecia recurren a la
cirugía estética para moldear su cuerpo
la mayoría aspira a parecerse a la
buchona una mujer curvilínea vinculada a
la narcocultura es también modo
aspiracional de ser como de estar como
de vivir en ese ambiente o de no vivirlo
simplemente estar a la moda y decir
Bueno yo no soy narcotraficante ni tengo
un novio ni pareja ni esposo que me
pague esta cirugías yo las las puedo
pagar y quiero estar quiero ser como
ellas en las calles de la ciudad abundan
las clínicas de cirugía estética en las
redes sociales en las páginas
especializadas ofrecen resultados
espectaculares a tarifas atractivas pero
la mayoría de médicos que operan detrás
de estas páginas no son cirujanos
mutilan a sus pacientes que luego van a
parar a la mesa de operación de la
doctora Martínez Terrazas tiene
desgarrado el músculo el pectoral y hay
que reconstruirlo porque en ciertas
actividades le genera dolor el implante
se va hacia arriba le genera molestias
Cristina una mujer de 28 años se hizo
implantar hace un año y medio las
prótesis mamarias por un médico sin
diploma en cirugía estética Poco después
de la operación sintió un dolor anormal
pues me fui a operar otra vez y me
volvió a cobrar llegó un momento en que
le había dicho doctor ya no aguanto pues
ya lo único que lo único que hay me dijo
para esto Pues toma o ponte unos parches
de morfina algo así la cueva prisa es la
autoridad sanitaria que está al acecho
de estas clínicas clandestinas desde
enero de 2022 en los 168
establecimientos inspeccionados en
Sinaloa 28 fueron cerrados
se ve una cama muy simple Se ve que
existe una ventana misma es que no
pueden existir porque favorece la
contaminación del área hace 18 años
Leticia fue invitada por una amiga a su
casa para llevar a cabo una supuesta
inyección de ácido hialurónico en las
nalgas ahora ella es una de las llamadas
modelos enfermas a los cinco años se me
empezó a oscurecer la piel
y
después de oscurecer la piel se me
empezó a adelgazar mucho entonces una
vez me golpeé
caí para atrás sentada y sangre tanto
que que no podía parar de de sangrar un
proyecto de ley para perseguir
judicialmente a estos médicos no
calificados e impedirles ejercer está
siendo estudiado por el congreso el
debate podría tomar un año
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Andrés doncell Sigan
viendo France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]